um
hospitals
yes
wow
yeah sure
okay
[Music]
[Music]
flippers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right we'll get everyone in soon
[Music]
i can do the second wave but there's too
many
well no no because
um
or you know sides or whatever just
tap whoever's here to get a rotation
going for the tire first
and so we're just gonna start rotating
here that'll need to start the rotation
so you'll go back to where graham is and
we'll go up there
uh
[Music]
okay
[Music]
hey
[Music]
um
so
uh
um
okay
okay
so
turkey
just like that
foreign
so
hmm
thank you
hey
oh
he said he was fundraising for his
office right yeah
it's like
[Music]
right
all right
what i really thought
hmm
mhm
um
um
thank you
[Music]
i knew you'd like
an answer begets a question
um
okay
thank you
okay
um
um
oh god
um
hmm
oh
membership
i don't know i just can't believe
your social
[Music]
um
is
this is laughing
well
um
okay
you
okay
good morning good morning everyone
another happy day joe biden
with president-elect this week
our nation paused for the sacred
observance of veterans
day every day we honor our veterans but
one day specially set aside just as the
military leaves no one
no soldier on the field in battle
when they come home our commitment is to
leave no
veteran behind this morning it was my
honor to be joined by the
chair of the veterans affairs committee
john
chairman mark takano as we enrolled
signed the veterans compact act critical
legislation
to prevent veteran suicide as our nation
confronts the accelerating coronal virus
crisis
which it's important to note that this
has affected tens
of thousands of veterans and va workers
it is imperative that we secure even
more funding
to support the va and care for our
veterans and their families
i also had the privilege of
participating in the uh
the work of elizabeth dole for the
observance that
she had on veterans day
this year now it was in cars at the
kennedy center
and some of us were a virtual but
secretary senator elizabeth dole has
been an
angel for our veterans and i was honored
to be asked by her
to join senator john mccain and others
to be part of
the initiative to honor our hidden
heroes uh the families that care for our
veterans
thank you elizabeth dole for all of that
again the as we honor the needs of
veterans in every area we must recognize
that it's not just the va
uh that meets their needs it's the role
that veterans
small better and small businesses play
and we want more opportunity for that
many our veterans rely on medicaid
they constantly come to us and say that
the medicaid piece is important to their
lives food stamps and housing assistance
so many of the things that we have
actually in the coronavirus bill
the heroes bill affect our veterans
yesterday on a separate associated with
this
yesterday as you're probably aware
leader schumer and i
had a call with president elect joe
biden
um we'll stay in close touch in the
coming days
we spoke about the intestine pandemic
epidemic
pandemic and the economic crisis
accompanying it
and about the urgent need for congress
to pass a bipartisan bill
in the lame duck session that provides
resources to fight the pandemic and
relief
for working families and small
businesses
support for state and local governments
to keep the frontline workers on the
payroll
and engage expanded unemployment
insurance
and affordable health health care for
families
the health care piece of course being
essential at the same time
as you know uh earlier in the week the
administration was instead of crushing
the virus trying to crush
the affordable care act and of course we
were very pleased that the presentations
that were made in support of the
affordable care act
in the courts but on our call back to
our call
that wasn't our call we also discussed
the need for bipartisan solutions to
create
millions of good-paying jobs including
through investments in infrastructure
manufacturing
research and development and clean
energy
infrastructure legislation has largely
not been
a partisan issue we believe this is a
good place where we can find
common ground but that that is something
we can work on now but
as we go into the new congress but for
now
uh the two areas of the coronavirus
and also to pass an omnibus bill uh in a
bipartisan way
i'm optimistic that that will happen
i've had
my current i'm an appropriator so i have
a good rapport with the appropriators
and i think that left to their own
devices they can get this
done as i've said before and uh
chairman shelby and i had this
conversation assuring each other that we
want
to have a bill again
our focus in the congress now in this uh
lame duck it continues to be on covet
relief
this is a red alert all hands on deck
as chairman uh leader schumer and i
discussed yesterday this is a mag an
emergency of the highest magnitude
and yet our republican colleagues want
to focus
elsewhere instead of recognizing us the
health emergency which science
has given us a path uh to
uh to crush just let's again
we had worse numbers than even yesterday
numbers speak very eloquently 160
000 infections were reported a
horrifying number
following more than a week of over 100
000 infections a day
these levels are two times higher than
the summer peak
more than 67 000 americans are
hospitalized with kobit
not a new record threatening
overwhelming our hospitals
and our hospitals in our rural areas too
over 10 million people have been
infected over 10
million people 240 000 americans
have died because of this pandemic
according to a news report this morning
which i'm sure you have all seen
it was reported that more than 130
secret service agents are infected or
quarantining in the wake of trump's
reckless campaign schedule
130 secret service
agents meanwhile on the economic front
over 20 million americans are on
unemployment america has a million fewer
teachers and
education jobs compared to a year ago
and that has an impact
on our children's education 8 million
people have fallen
into poverty 17 million children are
food insecure
there's no time to waste we must save
lives
and livelihoods and yet
republicans in congress continue their
tactics of delay
distort and deny which has led to deaths
has led to deaths now by and now they're
trying to distract
uh and divide the country as they refuse
to accept the election results
the election is over joe biden is the
president-elect
elected with a mandate of over 78
million votes but don't take it from me
the elections infrastructure government
coordinating council
and the election infrastructure sector
coordinating executive committees
said in their joint statement this
november 3rd election
was the most secure in american history
there is no evidence that any voting
system deleted or lost votes
changed votes or was any way compromised
it went on to say while we know there
are many unfounded claims and
opportunities for misinformation
and the process of our elections we can
assure you
that we have the utmost confidence in
the security and integrity of our
elections
and you should too
the republicans shamefully are
pretending otherwise are doing
serious damage to our american democracy
here and as viewed throughout the world
and making it even harder to address the
massive health
and economic crisis facing america
right now the longer the republicans
keep up
the charade the further out of control
the
probit crisis will spiral and more
endangered
americans will be i urge our republicans
to accept the facts
acknowledge the crisis and immediately
come to the table
uh to work on covert relief
again this takes place at a time where
there's a
vaccine on the horizon giving people
hope
but that should also give them um
uh encouragement to listen to science
on the way to the vaccine
testing tracing treatment mask wearing
isolation separation sanitation all of
those
things because the sooner we do that
and the sooner we have a vaccine
the sooner we crush the virus i hope it
would be
an incentive for people to follow
science
all the way to the vaccine and in that
score
in our cobit bill we do have sufficient
fund
a great deal of funding for the vaccine
the development as i said yesterday
should be
uh taken up under the defense
the defense bill it's just i just don't
know why the president
is not doing that and then also we want
to make
sure that when the vaccine occurs there
will be
sufficient funding and sufficient
vaccine to reach
everyone in our country as well as in
the world
because as we all know unless we're all
secure
none of us is any questions yes ma'am
a record number of women uh republican
women have been elected to
congress this year republicans are
saying it's the year of the republican
women is it
well i'm excited that we have more women
in congress that doesn't mean we have
a shared views but hopefully we can find
common ground
on some some issues that related to
domestic violence force
how the women's caucus in a bipartisan
way came together
in the beginning uh issues that relate
to
teen pregnancy have been a bipartisan
focus
over time reducing that so let's see
let's be optimistic and let us see
but i congratulate and welcome each and
every one of them of course we have
90 we have i think nine or ten new women
coming in
uh to our our caucus this time uh
we're sadly leaving nita lowy he's in
davis a few of the
uh women in the congress so um but we're
happy to have
all these new members and they're
beautifully diverse
so obviously you're going to have a
narrow majority here
you always talk about know your power
what is your power right now
what is your power right now with a
smaller majority
pressures inside the caucus and your
route to the speakership when you lost
those lines
well let me just say on that score and
we are still
very much involved in these races we
have a number that are
just haven't been counted uh when we
were impatiently waiting for the count
on the presidential it seemed like an
eternity and now it's
another week later so we're still
involved in that
but uh listen we had a very
deep victory two years ago
i don't think that people are quite
understanding of the 40 seats that we
won
31 were in trump districts he wasn't
on the ballot and right away we said
he's going to be on the ballot
that's a steeper climb in these
districts and with the actions that were
taken
we saved most of those seats so we're
very proud of that
we now have a president of our party
in the white house joe biden we have a
majority
in the house albeit smaller but
nonetheless uh
a majority 132
gavels chairs of committees
subcommittees and the rest
the beautiful diversity of our caucus
and we see it as a tremendous
opportunity as we go forward because we
have to address
the fact is that president trump to his
credit
turned out a big vote and in some of
these districts which were
people wondered how we won them before
they were so trumpian
and now with him on the ballot uh
bringing a bigger vote
but we're getting ready already for the
next time a number of our candidates
have already said they're going to run
again i'm not going to make any
announcements for anybody but a number
of them have told me that they're ready
they loved being in congress they were
proud to have won
and they were proud of the campaign that
they made
after joe biden was declared the winner
on a
saturday i spent most of the weekend
listening to those who did not
win the election they succeeded in their
campaign in terms of
putting forth their views but will not
be coming to congress right now
i have pages in fact books of notes
about how they saw
what happened in their districts and how
they
see how we go forward and it's clear
that a number of the people
who uh there are certain issues that may
have worked either
one place or another but we are we have
to have a deep dive we have to really
have the data
and so all of them gave me their view
for the moment
and said when we get more data we'll
have a clearer picture
by having a smaller majority and what
that means for both the caucus
and for your people may i remind you
that we have a president
of the united states we have a president
of the united states that is so
very important and whether you're in the
minority or majority if the president is
of your party
you have more power and uh i think that
that's what
mitch mcconnell is going to find out now
uh that that whether he's in the
majority of the minority
not having donald trump in the white
house is going to change
his leverage and that dynamic but i'm
very proud
i'm very proud uh i uh i knew it was
hard
in terms of what we did before i never
said uh that we were gonna pick
all these pollsters did and that's
another question about the polling and
the rest and the over estimation of what
could be there
but the fact is president trump got out
his vote
and in those districts some of them he
made a difference
and all every majority is fragile but
we're well on our way to the next
election
as we are counting still for this
uh have a running start with some of
these same candidates saying that they
will run
and others who are waiting uh because of
their own personal decisions
to run next time
the president continues as you noted to
falsely claim that he won the election
in one form or another his allies are
making unfounded claims about
irregularities with voting machines
we've seen the social media companies be
forced to step in and crack down
i'm curious from your perspective have
you seen big tech do enough specifically
a website like facebook to correct the
president's lives
i'm not a big fan of facebook i don't
know what they have been doing but i
know they've been part of the problem
all along and i just referred back to
the elections infrastructure government
coordinating council on the election
infrastructure sector
coordinating executive committees and
what they said
the number third election was the most
secure in american history
there's no evidence that any voting
system was deleted or lost votes
change votes or want any way compromised
and this is so
important because
we've had resistance from the other side
in protecting the critical
infrastructure of our elections it's the
mechanics of it and and this is a good
report back that things were going well
two to your point what is happening in
the social media
that is so poisonous to our system and
how do we have
uh a remedy for that uh it is
a social media the technology is a
blessing
but it's a double-edged sword in terms
of
communication democratizing the spread
of information
so i uh you know i would hope that they
would have some
sense of responsibility because they
were very much a part
of causing this problem to begin with uh
but i do also want to say
uh that with a president it's not just
another branch of government
the white house it is the bully pulpit
joe pot joe biden knows
why he's there he has a plan to be
effective for america's working families
and he will
have again he will have uh the stage
so it's not as if we're trying to get a
distinction made here and
press is engaged in equivalence and
which i think was unfair
but nonetheless in terms of having the
bully pulpit
it's not just a branch of government
it's not just a
uh having the white house not just a
branch of government not
just a um uh appointments to jobs and
a cabinet arrest it's the connection
with the american people
president lincoln public sentiment is
everything
with it you can accomplish almost
anything without it practically
nothing and it uh leapfrogs over so many
other
misrepresentations uh i hope
that the uh that everybody will give joe
biden a chance to have his message
out there what i saw during the trump
administration is he could say
anything it would be two days worth of
news whether it had any value
or not uh let's hope that everyone will
give
joe biden the chance he is the president
78 million votes and still
counting a mandate a mandate in our
country
so my confidence and my hope springs
from the public
the american people are so good
they're very clear about meeting their
needs and one of the messages for us
and all of this uh is the clarity
that behooves us to say this some of the
fears that they have
automation globalization
diversity climate issues and the rest
we want them to know that what we're
talking about is we're all going down
this path
together this is not a zero-sum game
if one person wins another person loses
no
and there is a place in the future for
every person
in our country and how we use the
automation the
globalization uh and those issues
uh in a way uh to give them that
assurance
and those jobs i said yesterday it's a
four-letter word i say it all the time a
four-letter word
jobs jobs jobs jobs which contribute not
only to
the economic health of families but the
health and well-being
of america's families yes
the smaller majority how does that
affect your legislative approach are you
going to have to compromise more are
there bills that you're not going to be
able to put on the floor
no not at all we have a president of the
united states
remember we're going to have the
opportunity to have bill
signed into law i'm very proud of our
caucus because we're beautifully diverse
as i always say it is a uh
our diversity is our strength our unity
is our power
and our unity springs from our
commitment to america's working families
and that is what we'll be talking about
as i mentioned putting together
uh and a jobs bill that involves
building the infrastructure of america
in a great
resilient and green way doing so in a
bipartisan way doing so that
everybody in our country benefits both
with jobs with workforce development
and with the services schools etc
housing
in their areas so it won't have that
much effect at all
from republicans in the senate
especially if they keep the majority so
how do you
shift your approach yeah i think you're
making a
more of a um
as i said we had a very big win in the
last election
it is smaller and now uh but it is not
uh and we still have the power of
of the majority but on top of that
our leverage and our power is greatly
enhanced
by having a democratic president in the
white house
especially joe biden who is the man he
is the one who
will uh put forth an agenda and will
work together
on that as we have done as we did
with president obama and joe biden as
vice president of the united states
i don't see that as any challenge at all
i see it as an opportunity
thank you madam speaker um on what you
said about
leader mcconnell can you expand on that
you said he's gonna find out what what
do you mean
well he's been known to come from my
office and say i'm not doing anything
donald trump doesn't want so to me that
was like an abdication
of your first branch of government
responsibilities
you're just going to do whatever the
president wants no this
is a a separation of power
something very very important the genius
of our constitution
the separation of powers and if we're
just saying
whatever the president wants and we're
not having the input or the
shall we say um
scrutiny as to what the best way to go
is
listening to the beautiful uh diversity
of our
of our our caucuses then we are
deserving
the american people so there's no
look there's no question when you're
president
the president is a president of your
party your leverage and your power is
greatly increased
you must know that you must know that
so again for the good of the country i
am so overjoyed that joe biden is
president of the united states
his decency his vision his values
his his authenticity
and his connection with america's
working families
so i i couldn't be more thrilled but i
also
know that he respects the legislative
branch
and that there's a collaboration and we
work together to put legislation
together
that will be hopefully bipartisan and
signed into law
but again the big partner in all of this
is the public the american people
they want they want
access to health care especially during
a pandemic they want good paying jobs
they want clean government that was our
agenda in 2018 it continues to be
for the people lower health care costs
by lowering the cost of prescription
drugs preserving the pre-existing
condition
for the people bigger paychecks by
building the infrastructure
of america in a green resilient way for
the people
cleaner government hr one which will
this time be hr one again
uh to end uh the role of big dark money
and politics is also
will um end the uh some a lot of the uh
voter suppression that is out there so
we we couldn't
be more thrilled we're sad to have lost
some of our members
as i say many of them are ready to come
right on back some want to be in the
biden administration all of them proud
of their
uh their campaigns and uh
i think universally
thrilled that joe biden is president of
the united states
thank you all
for winning a majority
[Music]